okay hello everyone it's Michael Volos
here from order flows.com and here is
today's orderflows market analysis for
Thursday February 23rd
2017 and are you tired of winning yet
Dow had its 10th consecutive uh High
barely closing up uh. 2% settled at
2810 uh interest rates were pretty much
unchanged a very boring day in the
interest rate Futures dollar Index uh
you saw a little bit of strength in the
Euro and the Yen I think there was Yen
around 101 now oil got back above 54
bucks despite a small build in the
weekly inventories and gold got a bid uh
up 15 bucks or so about uh up to
1250 and you know that said let's uh you
know let's take a look but before we get
started a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision
Futures TR contain substantial risk and
it's not for every investor an investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment risk capital is
money that could be lost without jeopard
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future
results tools that I'll be using in this
presentation are the same um the
orderflows trader footprint chart uh
which is the footprint chart that I use
for my trading um to read the order flow
and I have three proprietary indicators
that you know we've developed to read
the order flow sort of you know there's
many different ways of reading orderflow
and you know if I can take a few of them
off my head that I don't have to
necessarily always be looking for them
then you know frees up other space in my
brain yeah I know that sounds stupid but
um you know that that's how that's how
it works you know imagine you know there
there's so much information with
orderflow and you know you're always
trying to process everything and
sometimes you miss stuff because there's
just so much other stuff going on
especially if you're watching multiple
markets you just miss things and you
know have these indicators created to
sort of whack me upside the head and say
hey stupid um you know this is happening
in the order flow right now take a look
at it you know it's not these are not
red light green light indicators they're
more of hey idiot look here at this
Market analyze it and decide if you want
to take a trade so uh that said let's
get started I'll take a look at first
The e- Minis okay so coming in to the
the morning session you know 7:00
Chicago time very tight range um 64 and
a half was the high 59 was the low you
know so what is that five and a half
points and you know what can you do you
can't get too excited about
it in the sense that you know there's
really not much happening and I mean I
don't say don't get excited but you know
what when when you're coming in on these
very wound up days wound up in the sense
there's not been a lot of volatility
overnight you know be careful if if we
start breaking out of these ranges um
you know we could see some range
extensions either to the upside or to
the downside the tricky part is which
way we going to go we going to go up
we're going to go down so coming into
the morning um just before 8:00 we got
stacked buying and balance smallish
numbers 284 219 756 against very small
volume you know 409 47
33 yeah I was interested in that cuz we
did make a new high but again you know
it's right ahead of the cash open and
it's you it's just not chunky you know
it's not big you know at that time
you're not going to get big numbers in
terms of volume but you know at the same
time it's it's just very light here it's
just you know maybe someone came in and
said hey buy me uh you know 100 bucks
worth of V minis you know so that's
about I you know off top of my head I
don't know 6 700 know maybe maybe less
but you know maybe about 700 contracts
or something I don't know I have to do
the math but you know maybe there's just
an order like that hit the hit the hit
the screens you don't know um so we did
go he did go up made a new high up here
in an 809 okay do have this
um imbalance here uh 115 against 265
again you know it's right in that second
slot I find this to be kind of bearish
actually you know add a high here like
this get this everyone's coming in
thinking Hey We're Off to the Races and
get another big upd and you know people
are starting to Pile in head of cash
open saying hey you know what let's get
let's get long
and and you know see how high we take it
but you know what happens they can't
take it any higher they take it a tick
higher and it starts to come off comes
off a little bit back into this area
where you have this this imbalance
before and then get this down
um and we just come back up to the high
circle around back up to it you know
it's right ahead of the cash open you're
starting to see some buying imbalances
in there but again I'm not too
interested in in taking these things
right ahead of the cash open I'll let
the cash open settle out and you know
we'll see we'll go from there if if uh
you know if if the Market's going to
flex itself one way or the other so we
hit this High got a ratio got a
Divergence right on you right ahead of
the cash open 828 couple minutes before
come off go sideways literally um you
know sideways to
lower get into this area in here I
thought this area now notice when we're
at this High here so negative Delta
negative Delta small Delta here um you
know some more negative Deltas so we're
up here near the high right cash is
opening and what do you got you got
mostly sellers right so you got to keep
that in you in the back of your head
you're at your high of the day and for
the most part it's just all you know
it's just all negative Delta I mean
there you do get one or two bars with
some strong buying okay fair enough but
I mean it's broken out you know it's not
all right there so you know there's a
bit of selling pressure on the market
early and you know we get to this point
here at uh just before
9:00 you I get the Delta surge right
here so you know we're going sideways
thing was you know on it's not showing
now but on the volume profile at this
time if if you're watching the profile
this was your point of control for the
day right here this level um 64 63 and
3/4 and you're getting signals right
that the you know I don't like to take
signals right at your point of control
for the day which is generally going to
be right smack dab in the middle of your
value area for you know at that moment
just because you know your value why you
know what is value right it's the area
where everyone's happy to trade and
that's where you're going to get a lot
of volume you know trading you know back
and forth people that got to move sides
are going to do it when there's the most
volume available and that it's going to
be right at your right in the middle of
of your value area often
times so uh you know so I wasn't
interested in this and it came right
back with the Stacked uh buying and
balance literally at the same
level then we sort of hit this high up
here you know 64 and
3/4 then you got a big imbalance another
imbalance another imbalance okay but
we're still in that area you know we're
putting through some decent size you you
can see a couple thousand here 4,000
there 2,000
2,000 but then we started falling off
okay boom boom boom uh 2,000 you know
more imbalances 2,300
1400 okay and you see the just all
negative Deltas very strong and what do
we do do we come down towards the low
get a small bounce make a new run at the
low take out the low you know and then
we just sort of hang around this low
this is 9:30 in the morning still
hanging around but look at this
okay um let me close this
down you you do have a positive Delta
here a positive Delta here but these are
isolated you know and and look you got
negative Deltas strong negative Deltas
uh and more importantly look at the
footprint you've got uh 1083 you got 688
867 900 1100 imbalances selling
imbalances so even though you know there
there's buyers down here the sellers are
Relentless they they keep selling into
them you know you're getting these
imbalances all over the place you know
which is not a good sign and what
happens you go take out the Low by a
tick whoop-de-doo um you got another
Divergence but it's still you know I'm
still not vinced that this is going to
be the low yet and then we just sort of
hang around you know again poke down
through the low again you know make some
new lows here you can see it really
starting to pick up again um another big
strong you know you do have these small
buying in balances 700 500 10098 that's
small compared to you know 2,
1,800 so you know sellers are are
obviously in control at that point um
then we come down here hit
55 you know sort of bounce up a little
bit go sideways then continue again
another wave so what time is this this a
10:08
954 you know 928 so you know it's coming
in waves you can just sort of see it
often times you know when it's a
trending Market it's trending down at
this point at at uh I mean to what point
is it going to get well that's that's
the million-dollar question right
everybody wants to know well how how low
are you going to go um and honestly it's
it's not an easy
not an easy um it's not an easy thing to
to figure out so you know what you're
always going to be looking for is you
know signs
that the the whoops signs that the low
has been
made so going back okay you got you know
Divergence Divergence no Divergence
here you do have you know a Divergence
with a ratio you know points and
controls all along the bottom here do
Doom um but still you know what's the
sign is there any sign yet that we're
going to be pulling away not yet nothing
um here you got a nice stacked imbalance
I like getting imbalances off the lows
you know rather than take balances up
near the high because at least you know
it's showing that there's buyers coming
in and that's what you want and what
happens this is where the rally off the
low basically starts okay so you have
the Stacked imbalance not the greatest
numbers as well you know you're talking
195 against against 1 37 against 480 92
against
465 but nevertheless um it just sort of
hangs in there for the next two or three
bars and then it starts and then look at
these look at this aggressive buying 900
1 1200 2300 1400 you know if if you're
not convinced by now you should be and
you know the other thing is right if
you're going to really pull away from
this low
right uh where's my mouse
watch the Deltas okay you know 596 100
66 600 you know they're still negative
but they're getting they're small 66 78
121 you're sort of coming into this area
where trade is even you know you don't
have big Deltas one way or the other
necessarily I mean you know 6 yeah 600's
decent but you know it's it's the one
among um it's the giant among the the
Lily puts
so you're coming into this area where
you know it's you got 9,000 trades you
got Delta of 66 you know 4,000 a Delta
of 78 um 3,700 a Delta of
121 now you see the Delta is really
starting to get
aggressive know big uh 1125
1236 start working your way up okay come
back down Delta's still not that big on
the cell side this one's big 1300 but
200 no 571 68 again kind of small now
watch 3 373 800 25 small 417 okay decent
not the greatest 700
400,00 um the negative you know decent
positive it's it's going back and forth
at this point but we're going sideways
right so we sort of found this new level
off the lows that we were at
earlier um you know before down here you
know this is around the 53 54 area right
we're going sideways we got the small
Deltas well we moved away from that we
found a new level up here where you know
we're just sort of going sideways again
you know alternating
Deltas negative positive negative
positive not really moving
anywhere and you know you're just
looking you know for some more signs you
know are we going up are we going down
um at this point I'm looking at this I
remember
thinking maybe we might start heading
back down but what happened you know
again you get a bullish sign here
another bullish
sign and you know a nice big strong
positive
Delta then you're again it's Off to the
Races again back back on
up you know nice big imbalances working
your way back up um you here's the Delta
surge given a
buy doesn't really go anywhere it just
sort of goes sideways now we're starting
to hang around unchanged again at UH
60 62 that area um you know which we
just sort of hang around for the next
uh the next I'll say the rest of the day
but for the next couple hours um before
getting this sort of late rally late in
the day so there really wasn't
much opportunity in the e- minis you
know based
on based on that okay
now the difference is right so if if
you're reading that so that's that's a
three- range chart
so most people have you know all sorts
of different uh different charts open
you know minute charts uh what do you
want to call you know minute charts
mostly you know range charts you know
different types of range charts now on
the 10 range
chart there was something that was very
telling um and I I remember I I talked
about it in the
room and where is it here you know this
is the the thumbnail that I use on the
video
actually and you know this is something
that that I've talked about for but it's
not something you see all the time and
what is it here close
this it's just watching the Deltas let's
just watch these Deltas so we come up to
the high you you do have this negative
Delta you start coming down and then
Wham right here third bar off the high
look at this Delta minus 11,000 that's
massive you know that's massive you
don't need any sort of indicator or
anything to to tell you that you just
look at that number and you say oh my
gosh that's so big and you know on a 10
range
chart when I see the Delta either go Max
Delta or Min Delta at any point in the
bar over 10,000 Just go with it you
could almost just close your eyes press
buy or press sell whichever way the
Market's
going and you know put a stop in Five
Points away and put a Target five points
away and you know we went down from 62
down to what was the the low down here
55 so you know it was it was a decent
move you could have at least gotten five
points out of it but you know again you
know watch watch
watch the Delta volumes um you know that
that's something that you don't need any
fancy indicator for doesn't happen very
often maybe once a month if that you
know I'll say once a month but you may
go a month with it not happening and
then you know then the next month it
happens uh you know three times or
something like that or you know it it
doesn't happen for a month and then it
happens two days in a row it's uh it's
it's really kind of you know the
Market's fickle in that sense sometimes
um the
bonds you know bonds is
really very quiet today actually and you
know but there was there was some things
early you know again I had talked about
this yesterday I'd written about it
before and it's this here so we have
this High um just before
8:00 you got a circle around it right
you got the Divergence you got the
ratio got a strong negative
Delta and what happens Market goes
sideways on you this is the o2x I used
to have a free download on my website I
got to check if it's still up there
maybe I I'll put a link into it uh in
the video or I'll I'll write about it
again on my website but what it is it's
the o2x and this is the O so you got a
new high or new low in this case it's a
new high that's your o you put a circle
around that high and what you're going
to be looking for is you're going to
look for a pullback within two ticks of
that high so the high is 152 even
you come back up here to 30 1
15130 it did go bid there so you know
you would have been filled if not you
know you'd still be sitting working an
offer up here that you would been filled
on we got through it and your stop is
just one tick above that high so
15201 so you know you can sell it at 30
your stops at
01 so that's a three- tick stop all
right that's pretty tight and you your
profit Target should be at least you
know5 ticks six ticks or more honestly I
was looking you know for a move down
into this area down here
22 um didn't really you happen well we
say didn't happen actually I'm take that
back I was looking for a move below 20
um but so we pulled back up here so he
would have been filled and actually you
got more of a bearish thing here you've
got imbalance here so you got everyone
buying it on the way back up you know
price action Traders saying oh we got
our pullback now let's buy it and and go
higher okay but they're stopped in their
tracks here someone came in and sold the
heck out of it you got this imbalance
here you got unfinished business here
got a ratio point of control right at
the top so you got you know one two
three things going on for you the only
thing you don't have is is a negative
Delta but you don't have it because you
got that big imbalance and then you make
that move down to 22 um so you know had
you been able to sell it at 30 you know
if you're covering it somewhere around
23 24 25 you know that's five six ticks
right there um you know we hit that came
bounced back up hit it again um we
circled back up towards there later but
I mean really that was you this was
almost you know I want say textbook you
know it would have been textbook if you
know we got right up here and then made
the move down but you you said you can
only do what the Market's uh what the
Market's going to let you do
so it's one of those things you know I
didn't even check this here but um
I'm just curious from this
high whoops take that
[Music]
out yeah so you know from this low to
the high you get your pull back in here
it's not a 38 you know it's not a fib
retracement you know FIB would have been
down here at 20 23 you know it's only
down to 25 26 you know it's cuz I was
trying to figure out you know if these
guys are trying to play this pullback to
take it higher or not you know it's kind
of a stretch that that they would have
done it but yeah I'm always looking at
things like that you know even here
this is like half back
even just about half back you see
that this level here at 20 would be uh
50% retracement from this from the low
up to this this High here so again you
know this is twice CU I kept wondering
why we keep busting back down to this
level you know and then people are
trying to again take it higher well
that's what you got you got these
pullbacks you know people are
playing these you know these you know
price action guys keep trying to play
these pullbacks and break out to new
High they finally got the breakout but
you know as much too uh the Market's
closed already um at this time 4:00 he's
like got it break out right after the
close
so you let's take a look now at at some
of these other indicators um you know
that was just the basic basic uh price
action but if you're looking at you know
okay the transition
how it
do let's go back well 6 o'clock again
I'm not too interested in that
time I gave a decent sell here nice buy
Here 55 all the way up to the 60s um the
little sell maybe could got something
this one no nothing well I'll say
nothing this one just went sideways this
one n probably taking a loss
2:00 no probably would had a small loss
there let's uh take a look at the 980
the group of 987 ticket charts I just
had that one up cuz it was just to the
side real quick so start 987 tick these
are the same charts I pull up every day
okay don't say ah you're just showing
the charts where you know things worked
if it doesn't work I I show it um you
know I'm not I could care less if you
guys think um you know my my stuff's
decent or not you know this is what I
use in my trading actually you know and
there's people there that that are using
it as well so
um whatever you know everyone has their
own way of analyzing the markets
so uh what do you got here so at this
High you got to sell um it's just sort
of went sideways on you before falling
off here got to buy not much I mean it
looks it looks nice but you know this is
eight range or 9 rather 987 tick chart
this is not that big a move from uh 90
to
95 a very again you know euro currency
was in a
pretty quiet mode
today and what else we
got bonds you know bonds nothing um
bonds was know snooze session today said
you know even in the orderflow it was
just that one you know at this High here
that was the only decent um decent thing
but there's no signals there on that
transition uh what else we
got um e Minis
okay where are we here well
that's excuse me
8:30 838 you get a big upar does
nothing does nothing does
nothing so maybe a small loss small loss
small loss three losses oh your
indicator suck look at this you buy and
it sold off you buy you sold off you buy
and you sold off so okay let me put it
to you this
way you're buying it here
5 and a half getting stopped out here 4
and a half four and a quarter so lose a
point and a half again lose
another 70 60 and
3/4s you know point and a half a
point call the 60 you get out of 50
another point so you lose one two three
and a half points
okay curse me but then look at this you
know you're getting long at 55 you get a
move all the way up here so you lost
three losing trades you lost three and a
half points fourth
trade you get it all back in you're in
the red or sorry in the in the red in
the BL in the black so you lost three
and a half then you got five points back
lost something there um you know then
just sort of this one didn't work out um
this one again decent one so and again
you know there's ways you can eliminate
take in signals like this
or this or even any of these
other you know there's a way you could
eliminate taken that this one you know
maybe you would have taken this one you
could have not taken you know but I've
talked about that in in other videos and
I'll probably create another video about
it you know it's basically let the
market take you in let the market start
moving the market can't even take out
the high of the bar that gives you the
entry you know that gives you the signal
then then don't don't get into the trade
if you can't even beat the high by a
tick then it's probably not going to
work out you know if it can't even
extend it by a tick just like here um
look at
this right this is the low he's telling
you to get short and the next bar we
can't even get past that level so you
know is is it worth taking no of course
not
[Music]
and what else was there anything in the
crude I don't
know um crude I don't remember number I
wasn't really watching it this morning
um anyway yeah there's a sell here
didn't work
out what do you
got again you know you got a signal here
but you're never even anywhere near this
low should you be taking it no of course
not don't think I'm going to get a
better entry by uh
expand it out a bit make it easier to
see you know so this is your signal bar
okay and you have this low at 29 you
know you should at least let it trade 28
27 don't be thinking oh I got a signal
to get short here and I can get short
now at 31 I get a better fill no the
Market's moving in the wrong
direction you know at least this one you
know started to move you know so the top
of this bar or even you know this bar
right so the low of this bar 41 you know
if you let it come down to 39 you know
got to stop in there to
enter or you know if Market you know
just let to come down there and then
enter you know getting in at 3839 at
least it makes a move down to you know
28 29 and same here you know you get
this move finally above 41 um you get up
to 42
43 you know at least it gives you at
least it's moving in that right
direction don't just take a a signal
because it says you got to take a signal
that's not what trading is you need to
analyze the the market and see what what
the heck is going on um just real quick
this is the Dow again the flip um I
think there was just one signal this
one's a little you again I'm not big on
trading the Dow before the cash opens
this I don't know what time this was
7 know 745 yeah it did go up but again I
for me I prefer to trade the Dow when
the cash is open this one didn't work
out
okay this is the flip this is a five
range um chart on the
Dow again the other flip is again let's
take a look at it from the cach
open you there were some signals back
here you know some work some didn't
but in case you're wondering what these
Aqua lines are this is the PLC Trader
just highlighting P important plcs this
one didn't work in the flip this one
did this one not really I think that
would have stopped you out take a loss
but then look at this you got the flip
here worked out nicely then get another
one really
quick you know from 7 I don't know what
you call this 770
765 all the way down to this area down
in here you know into the 30s or 40s
work your way back up
though and you know I mean you know
people drives me insane sometimes is
send me a chart yeah I got short here
okay or even here I got short on this
comes all the way down it's all in here
in here in here okay where'd you get out
thinking they got out somewhere in here
as it starts M no I got out up here I
took a loss Aya I mean come on uh Trail
your stop Trail your
stop I that's just something that that
comes with
um experience I guess I mean I don't say
it comes with experience but
you know managing the trade once you're
in it uh you know this was a little one
and then you know you know you got to be
careful with this I'll say careful um
that's the wrong choice of words when
you know this Market the way this
Market's been over uh the last several
months you know you're getting these
nice big
um rallies late in the day I so now when
I when it comes around 2:00 I'm always
looking are we going to get a uh are we
going to get a rally or not
um again this is Euro currency it's a
one minute chart this is the
transition go back to
7ish six it's a little early you know
here you're getting some you know 720
the floor
open when I think about that I still
hear the bell ringing in the back in my
head and again nice buy right at 720 up
to here a little sell comes down a
little buy this one doesn't work
out this one
you probably wouldn't have taken it
actually because again it doesn't take
you into the market and it goes one 2 3
4 5 six seven bars before it starts to
move this one's a little bit better you
know I like to give it a few bars you
know it doesn't necessar have to be the
next bar give it you know several this
one's a nice move
here again sell here the buy here but
then look at this you get this cell and
you know was at 10592 is that area look
at that that that's a beautiful move
down to
72 you know even that you get you know
thinking hey maybe I should cover it but
then you get some
more um bear signals so you could you
could keep it you know it doesn't really
go much further from that actually just
sort of hangs around then you run into
the 2:00 okay you might as well just
cover it you know um you don't want any
weird moves after 2:00 actually you know
honestly you have this move here and I
get this you get down in here and it's
already 1:00 I'd just be saying n screw
it I'll just cover it um yeah I'd
probably be looking to cover it in here
actually even before this this
happened I want to see if I got a uh a
chart on the
U-turn I haven't
uh I haven't seen one um I don't know if
I closed it down by accident
or or what
um I think it's one those I've got on on
a chart with everything let me uh that's
not
it just trying to find it here bear with
me okay well you know I got one here on
the bonds the bonds was pretty quiet I
was hoping to find one I got to I got to
make one for the uh Euro currency and
the crude and the E minis but so this is
the U-turn and it's you know trying to
pick Turning Point point in the market
so you know bonds you didn't Bond's very
quiet today very quiet I mean look at
this you know this is your range here
basically 152 to
15122 but you know it gave a couple
signals you know here's a buy you know
next two or three bars straight up
there's a sell bar down down down
another sell down you know so maybe you
could have got something out of it you
know for it's decent it's a decent uh
indicator um what else that one I did
already that was the
flip just
find I'll close it out with wait what's
that that's the Delta I'll finish it out
with the mini da the 100 range chart
which
was you one of my it's one of my
favorites to look at if I find it
100 tick chart mini da here it is you
know I said if if there was one thing
you could trade it would be mini da on
100 tick
chart and just go back okay well six 745
again I'm not too interested at that
point but nevertheless you it did give a
decent buy but I'm not uh not claiming
any Victory on that this one again it
didn't look at it okay get it tells you
to get short but it doesn't take out the
low so would you be interested I I don't
think it should be doesn't go
anywhere here nice one I you know would
have stopped you out you know take a
look you know this is the point that's
up open for discussion so 91 okay so let
it take you in get down to 88 you know
90 so the low of this bar is 91 the
signal bar 91 90 89 you even 88 okay
where you going to put your
stop you going to put it right above the
high at 94 that's I think that's a
little um tight 95 that's only one tick
you know maybe give it a little bit more
than um you know one tick above the high
you know it's up to you um where you're
putting your stop honestly I I can't sit
here and say you have to put it here or
you have to put it there um you know
that's a personal decision based on on
your risk tolerance but I I do think you
should have gotten into this trade and I
do think you hopefully would not have
been stopped out because if you did get
stopped out you'd feel like an idiot for
missing this this move from um you know
the the high 80s down into the the 60s
but then again it does give you some
more more opportunities here you know 73
down into the mid 60s um then another
one here you know doesn't stop you
out you know 770 so you're getting you
know maybe 68 you're getting
short and then you know from 68 down to
what you know down into the 40s you know
even just went sideways in here then you
know down into the 30s more cells in
here then you get a nice Buy Signal here
let the market take you in you know
here's your 29 is the high of this bar
you know let it trade up to 31 maybe get
you in you take some heat down to 25 you
know that's why I say you know don't
don't think that oh I have to put a stop
exactly five ticks you know from my
entry point monitor it you know we don't
get below the entry bar here you know
whereas on the other case I was showing
you we did right so yeah I don't think
you would have been stopped out on this
trade you know but if you're using if
you're coming in thinking no I'm just
going to use an arbitrary five tick stop
you that's where people run into trouble
they they think they could automate the
out of everything and if you're
automating your stop like that you're
you're not giving yourself any room and
you're going to get stopped out and
you're going to miss you're going to
miss moves like this you know so you say
you're getting in here at 31 or whatever
you know it's all the way back you know
even here you get another signal um but
you should have already been long you
know all the way back up to the the
70s you know so even if you got one of
these moves you know even here if you
got out and you're just sitting here
okay maybe get into this again you know
where are you going to place your stop
you know 78 you're getting in maybe you
know give it 10 ticks you know 68 you
would you have been stopped out well you
traded down here maybe maybe you would
have gotten tired of sitting in this
trade through all this time here where
it's just going sideways but then you
know gives you another opportunity you
know if trade is going sideways on you
don't let it come all the way down here
and stop you out then make the move
honestly if the trade's going sideways
for so many bars get out don't don't
stay in the trade you know there's going
to be other chances you know get out
save your bullets fight again um and it
gives you another chance right here
right so 74 you know maybe you're
getting in around
76 and it's never you know no draw no
draw down against you trades all the way
up straight up again you back up above
800 again I'm not saying oh you got to
take this or this no you should have
been long from
earlier short here you know 80 you know
the low of this is 806 so maybe
804 whatever getting short boom back
down again down to 770 and I'm not
saying you covered it down here no you
probably been looking to cover it
somewhere in here you know
8 780
worst um this one it went down then
started coming back it would have been
stopped out uh I think that's about it
there's a couple buys here you know this
one didn't work out this one
no um this is you know these this one
doesn't work out this one doesn't work
out again but that's only one
tick
so okay so thanks for watching this and
you know it's the website orderflows
dcom
just make sure you subscribe to the
channel there's yeah I try to put up a
new video you know whenever I can you
know if it's every day some days it's
every
day sometimes not but
uh you know don't be uh don't be shy
come in and learn more at my website
orderflows decom watch the videos on
this channel subscribe to the channel
and hope to see you on the inside
bye-bye